tasha maintenant on est parti pour une
interview 12 ou alors je vais te dire
des noms de 2 pp plus tôt et tu vas me
dire s'il ya eu quelque chose ou rien et
c'est y pas demander à mes proches à ce
gars tu sais qui est un avocat qui
fréquente chez les cadets relation
fantastique avec certains joueurs noirs
faut pas qu'on se méfie ouais enfin
juliette gréco par exemple tu as j'adore
ouais il s'est passé quelque chose à
travaux s'est passé plein de sous à
blain tapas problème d'avocats là ok ok
ça a duré longtemps de deux ans deux ans
et demi ouais alors jeanne moreau il ya
une aventure entre vous sûr que ça veut
dire les aventures tu le dis dans ton
lit ce cher sacha mais oui mais le mamba
mais non il n'y a pas moyen de faire une
idée sur les dommages qu'ils la ferment
d'une balle en tire lait il ya des
legends ou d'une vie et parce que
d'autres tu dis des choses légères et
anodine oreilles quelquefois c'est pas
très bien pris par certains mais on doit
y dong sont pas là dessus alors brigitte
bardot ça tu viens c'est indéniable la
rencontre est très belle parce que en
1956 tu superviser la bande son d'un
film qui s'appelle et dieu créa la femme
pour les productions de ray ventura qui
s'appelait versailles et tu vois arriver
un jour bébé qui était très en retard
elle était avec jean louis trintignant
dont est très très amoureuse est en
retard je sais pas avant le lazer c'est
qu'elle est en retard mais c'est pas
quel était le nouveau texte est alors à
ce moment là tu l'engueuler ça commence
vraiment comme les films américains tu
sais moi j'avais un louer un studio ea
coûté fort cher
pour le petit producteur que deux heures
elle est arrivée une heure en retard
mais quand même que ce n'est que ça
n'aurait pas eu d'engueulade c'est tout
alors évidemment donc la france entière
attend vos attentes vos fiançailles
oui moi cette époque là il fallait en
penser à se marier ses régulières et en
étant d'amandine marié aussi financé
pour voir si allah on essaie de voir si
puisse l'a pas fait ils ces domaines
pourquoi la rupture avec bardot parce
que parce que sais je sais que pour
rompre faut être deux ouais donc il ya
il ya l'un et l'autre des parties de
tourner un film donc j'étais pas là tout
le temps moi de mon côté j'avais pas
envie d'être le monsieur qui est
derrière toujours comme si tu avais pas
envie d'être monsieur bardot oui mais tu
es devenu l'ex fiancée de bardot s'était
pas mieux quand même beaucoup de je ne
sais pas moi je sais que je peux dire
c'est que maintenant ça c'était ans 58
ont en 92 ouais il y en a eu pas mal
derrière qui ont joué le rôle ray mais
s'il devait y avoir une raison je sais
pas look celle de michel il a quitté en
fait
ah oui deçà d'une femme puisqu'elle
s'est marié derrière il ya eu un enfant
oui même si toi tu voulais plus y penser
à bardos entend parler parce qu'un jour
l'arrivée à oran en fin de spectacle il
y avait quinze mille personnes quittent
on s'y fait pas ce qui est en train d
comme c'est charriées par moitié
d'histoire et plus je ne connais pas
quinze mille personnes si pour les cocus
qu'aucun homme ne s'était pas quinze
mille personnes c'est une personne avant
un but avait moins drôle non c'est
beaucoup plus grave que ça s'entend elle
n'entend pas souvent un petit peu comme
daf figurait tout d'un coup et non mais
les cages
la france par exemple tu vois entre deux
chansons c'est un cap du mortel
personnes en plein air met à crier cocu
je sais pas pourquoi je devrais te là
c'est plus moi maintenant c'est l'autre
était un sacré virage dans la tamise les
rieurs de mon côté à la tu m'as dit
quand même c'est elle qui m'a fait le
plus souffrir dans ma vie oui probable
épouse et ses mains quand tu es tout
jeune quand tu amoureux faut dire quand
même de la plus belle fille du monde
ouais quand même faut quand même dit
vais le dire elle est toujours une des
plus belles femmes du monde et que tu te
retrouve largué bombasse effet d'un
double position de de l'amoureux
éconduit sexe déjà pas drôle ce n'est
pas un rôle facile il y avait à
l'intérieur de soi et en plus et elle a
résisté dit montbard et peut-être encore
plus difficile alors bon bah tu cédé
finalement
il a vraiment souffert à connell pour le
china daily qui cite j'ai perdu un ami
elle rassure postulat perdu c'est que ce
n'était pas un navire est alors si ça
n'a pas marché c'est que ça ne peut pas
marcher un jour gros gros coup de foudre
donc tu rencontres ta femme s'était
butée enfin enfin on arrive aux jo 100
voilà tu as changé de vie je veux dire
c'était fini les boîtes les copains elle
t'a bien dressé un ouais c'est vrai
comment d'ailleurs à 2h des fiançailles
c'est vrai à 2h des fiançailles elle est
partie 15 jours pour réfléchir
maman c'est pas vrai c'est pas ça ne
vous demandiez d'avoir un déjeuner
fantastique avec mémé grand copain les
intimes toit dont claude brasseur dont
daniel cauchy que dit que les petites
années mais oui tu vas pas te marier tu
n'as pas de mari et moi je le savais dès
le départ cela j'ai dit cela si ça passe
ça s'est vérifié et c'est j'en suis
heureux et alors il fallait pas trop
compte les admiratrices tu vois c'est
comme si
patrick se marient demain timmer parler
vu arriver et imagine catastrophe
nationale à cette époque la bombe était
absent c'est dans ce genre de contexte
et et puis j'ai hésité puis francine
fait ce qu'il fallait faire mais bon je
partais faire une tournée canada etats
unis
elle me dit bon écoute ci s'est pas
décidé quand tu reviens dans un mois je
suis plus là mais elle n'était plus là
voilà je me suis retrouvé tout seul
elle en a fait voir en dix mois c'est à
faire donc trente ans de mariage
une toiture à 60 ans non attends ça fait
29 ans de mariage et 59 ans ça va assez
vite comme ça c'est pas la peine
physiquement ça va rentrer vous à tout
seul ça va bien est en train de tout ça
va bien j'ai un truc baptisée regards
des orages